i was just wondering if you had even the
advice
um
i let my
the mother of my child down recently
at least i have been for the past two
years and
i was a drunk
i'm finally realizing everything and
trying to be better but
apparently it's too late so you know
i was wondering if you had any advice
and how to keep on going man
love you
you help me get through the hardest
things
thank you so much to you
uh thank you bro for the call man um
i'm sorry that you're that you're
suffering uh
but also i'm glad that you are
you know uh
and i'll say this this is why i say that
um
because
you know it sounds like you have some
realization now you're able to get some
perspective maybe
that the way you've been operating has
investments servicing you
or those you care about the most
you know
you know i don't have a wife or child or
anything like that but
yeah it breaks my heart because i know
it breaks your heart man
you know
i know it breaks your heart to see you
make the choice
to not choose them
and that i can relate to
you know i can relate to making choices
that uh
that don't serve you
or me you know or you know i can relate
to making a choice
that i know isn't good for myself and i
do it again and again
i can relate to that man um
so that's where i'm gonna try to relate
to you at uh
[Music]
for one thank you for even thinking to
bring this up
you know because i'm sure a lot of
people struggle with this kind of stuff
and i say that i'm glad you're getting
you know you're so i'm glad you're
suffering i'm glad you're suffering but
i'm glad that you're having to some some
realization because there's some
realization there in that suffering
there's some perspective
um because we need that we need
something to adjust the perspective
enough so we can see that the operating
we're doing isn't doing us well
and if i'm not operating well then that
means that there's something wrong with
the operation or the operator that's me
there's something unaligned it's not
wrong it's just something on the line
because i'm not choosing the best
choices that are making me feel good
um
and so i got to adjust and for me that's
where you know going leaning back into
my program 12 steps that kind of stuff
helps immensely
it does magic behind the scenes that you
can't even quantify
[Music]
and it takes away that shame that's what
i hear in you too i hear shame
i hear shame man damn
and shame is what shame is that trick
shame is a trickster
shane's pla you know
shane plays a dirty trombone dog
that's a little soil soldier dog that's
all he's got
in that uh
and that music maker is sod bro because
he he's a dirty shame is a dirty because
you start hearing you feeling your own
shame and that that keeps you stuck
shame is a mud
it's a real mud
so anyway man i'm saying a lot of that
stuff because uh
now you have some perspective so now you
can see you got to make some adjustments
so that you making different choices
towards the people you care about the
most
um
and it's possible that's what i'm going
to tell you here i'll take these off too
i don't want to be talking serious with
you
not be able to see you or as best i can
um
[Music]
you know it's hard to choose love
sometimes in the world it's hard
it's hard
and i don't know why you're not doing it
in your life i don't know why
but there's a lot of people out there
not doing it
you know i've not done it a ton there's
areas of my life i'm not doing it
i'm choosing something else and i don't
know why
and you know what i don't exactly have
to figure out that why what what i do
have to do is just get myself into a
place where i'm choosing the things i
need to be choosing and so that's where
i believe that a 12-step program can
help you out
because that has been the best success
that i've had after all the things i've
tried
that program i feel like has best
given me the opportunity and the
different feelings inside
to have a new experience um
and it's not over with the gal that's
not over
she can't tell you that everything's
gonna be okay right now that's not fair
that'll keep you in the same spiral
you know
if she throws a life preserver into the
toilet you're still in the toilet
you know i'm saying baby you know we got
to get you into a damn bird bath dog
that's where we got to get you
um
so
just don't be hard on yourself
just try not try not to be hard on
yourself and i think try something
different you know i think trying a
12-step program will help a lot let me
listen to the end again so i can hear
just again in case i missed anything for
the past two years and i was a drunk
i'm
finally realizing everything and trying
to be better but
apparently it's too late so you know
i was wondering if you had any advice
and how to keep on going man
love you
and the advice will start to come from a
higher power and from the program so
that will help you
you'll get it it's it's interesting
it'll start to get built into you
you just keep going to meetings and keep
listening to people and i would go to
speaker meetings you can go to them on
zoom first if you feel more comfortable
um
and
because once you start to feel like you
can keep on going then you're going to
feel like you can go further but first
you got to feel like you can go
and then it will all evolve man i
promise you
i promise you
you will have other opportunities with
this
with this person with this child you'll
have all of that
you know
all those things are possible but now if
you know that something's wrong and you
continue to do you continue to do it
then you are kind of choosing to suffer
you know you said real
realized it you know you realize these
things so now you have knowledge so once
you have that knowledge if you continue
to do it
then you are choosing to suffer
you know uh
and sometimes you may make that choice
but if it's a continued thing maybe it's
you know and i just said i'm not judging
you i've done it
and that's where self-pity starts for me
i continue to stay in these loops and i
don't even recognize it
i just continue to want to have a re
some reason to suffer
um
[Music]
and i just don't want to see the same
thing happen to you man that's that's
happened to me before you know uh so
anyway just don't feel alone brother and
just keep your head up baby
you know
um
[Music]
because you're not alone man i mean
there's probably 500 000 people
listening to this that are thinking of
you
and that want you to want you to try
you know
they want you to try
you know and i want you to try to i know
it's hard man
it's hard bruh it's hard to [__] try
especially when you have there's a
feeling inside you like the world never
it never tried for you
this world never [__] tried for me
but that's that's just a feeling man
you know
and god gave you like a beautiful child
or whatever you believe in gave you a
beautiful child man and you got a voice
you have the ability to care about
yourself enough to call
you have gifts
you have gifts man and um
[Music]
and i believe that you can do it brother
i believe you can have a new experience
and that's what i want for you because
it seems like that's what you want for
you so
anyway man i'm not trying to preach at
you but uh just letting you know that uh
you're not alone baby okay
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one